STIRRING MUSIC
Sandi, you're gonna love me.
I've totally nailed the theme for
this week. I'm Lawrence of Arabia.
Wow, Lawrence of Arabia,
conqueror of the Arabian desert.
You think it's Desert Week.
OK, it's actually, uh, Dessert Week.
One S and my whole costume's ruined.
Save it for the Nativity play.
Start the show.
TOGETHER: Welcome to
the Great British Bake Off.
Thing is, what am
I going to do with the camel?
Stick it in Paul's trailer.
I can't. He's the back end.
I thought it looked lumpy.
Ooh, ooh!
Last time...
Whoa, BLEEP.
..we celebrated
the Roaring Twenties.
I went to Matt Lucas's 30th
birthday party as a flapper girl.
And whilst Steph's
stunning pina colada cake
secured her a second Star Baker...
Again!
..it was double despair...
Decoration.
..for Michelle...
That doesn't go with that,
and that doesn't go with that.
..and Helena.
God, it's melting.
I'm so sorry.
Oh, at least we go together.
We go together.
The thing I'm going
to miss the most is the other
bakers, without any doubt.
Now...
SIREN WAILS
..desserts...
Oh, it's all very stressful, isn't
it? ..are baked, layered...
God, this is not fun.
..and transformed...
Ugh! ..into explosive bombes.
Things can happen
between there and here.
Who will light the fuse?
How does this work?
And who will go out with a bang?
It looks like something
straight from a 1970s sweet trolley.
THEY LAUGH
So few...
I made it to week six!
Yay, week six!
Feels a bit weird.
There's not many of us left.
Being picked off one by one.
It's like an Agatha Christie novel.
This was the week I've been
terrified of,
like... I am not a dessert person.
I don't make
desserty things, no. No.
Hello, bakers,
welcome back to Dessert Week
and your Signature challenge,
a layered meringue cake.
Now, it needs to be a cake
made of meringue with layers.
Yeah, let's not get too
technical here. Really?
Basically, it needs
to be a large cake,
the sort you might
share with friends.
Needs to be
a minimum of three layers,
sandwiched with
some kind of filling.
You have two hours and 45 minutes.
On your marks... Get set...
Bake!
I've made pavlovas, never made
a meringue cake before,
but they're one and the same.
They're cousins or
like step-sisters.
My mum makes a pavlova every time
me or my sister goes home
in the summer.
It's quite a nice
dinner party kind of thing.
We used to have dinner parties,
then we had kids.
We want the bakers really
to create a beautifully
aesthetic meringue cake.
You want definition, you want peaks,
you want a bit of shape
to your meringue,
so when you look at it, you think,
"Wow, I want to eat that."
It seems quite simple, because
they can all make meringue,
they can all whip cream,
they can all know about flavour,
but the danger is,
because it's simple,
they will want to
over-complicate it.
Morning, David. Hello, David. Hello.
Tell us all about you meringue cake.
I'm doing mixed spice
and each meringue is flavoured
with a different spice.
This one is clove.
This one is cinnamon and
this one is star anise.
Do you think
each one of those go together?
Why would you ask that question?
I think they do.
Fresh figs and berries in
a vanilla cream will fill
David's spiced meringue layers.
Have you given it
to any of your friends?
No.
You've only practised
this on yourself?
Yeah, but I do like these
kind of mixed spice flavours.
I think you're
shooting for the moon.
I think this could either
be genius or a disaster,
but I admire that bravery.
I'm fearful about the meringue,
which is the bulk of the challenge.
So in Le Touquet, which is a little
coastal town in France,
there's loads of lovely patisseries,
and one of them does
this lovely pistachio and chocolate
mille-feuille thing,
and so this is a nice
little version of that.
Four giant layers
of pistachio meringue,
filled with chocolate
creme patissiere
and fresh raspberry jam,
topped with ornate chocolate work,
is Henry's opening bid to keep
his place in the competition.
Is it weird now there's just
seven of you? Is it strange?
It's like a lunge between each bench
now. That's how you can tell.
You were all kind of closer
together.
Yeah. So if you can do
two lunges between each bench,
you know you've got to the final.
Ooh, I see. We're going
to measure by lunge.
Yeah.
# Awkward bit of waiting time
Duh, duh, duh, duh, duh, duh. #
Waiting on my nuts.
Most of the bakers have chosen to
flavour their meringue with nuts.
I'm always waiting on nuts.
It's just my life...
..in a nutshell, as it were.
But one of them has opted
for a different approach.
Good morning, Rosie. Hello.
Right, tell us all about your
meringue cake. What are you doing?
Salted caramel French meringue,
and that's going to be topped with
a raspberry and lime curd
and then a chocolate ganache.
You're using fruit
and chocolate? Yeah.
Got the sharpness of the curd
to sort of cut through it,
because otherwise
everything's quite sweet.
Rosie's meringues will be
flavoured with fresh raspberries,
raspberry cream,
salted caramel,
a raspberry
and lime curd
and a decadent
chocolate ganache.
How confident are you feeling
at the moment in the Bake Off?
Last week was a massive
sort of confidence hit, so...
You thought you were going home
last week. I was absolutely certain
I was going.
I didn't think there was any
way... any way I wasn't going, so,
obviously, I want to sort of prove
that I earned my place here.
Well done. Good luck, then, Rosie.
Thank you very much. Thank you.
It's an arm workout and a half.
Rosie isn't the only baker...
Should've gone to the gym this week,
shouldn't I? ..going nut free.
I'm doing a Black Forest
gateau meringue cake.
I've played around with nuts
in there, but I wanted to
stick to the true...
Yeah, this is a nut-free...
Black Forest... Yeah.
Alice's chocolate meringue layers
will build to a Black Forest homage,
featuring chocolate mousse, cherry
buttercream and cherry compote.
What cherries did you
use for the compote?
Um, so these...
Just ordinary sweet cherries?
Yes, so they've got
quite a zing to them.
I mean, the flavours of a Black
Forest gateau in a meringue cake
should work... should work
beautifully.
All right, well, good luck.
Thank you.
Another baker giving a timeless
classic the meringue treatment...
Ooh.
..is Steph.
So I am making... hmm...
..Eton elegance.
Oh, there's all
the flavours in there.
Pistachios, raspberries,
white chocolate -
they're the main flavours.
Steph's pistachio-rich meringue
will be the foundation
of her Eton mess upgrade.
Filled with raspberries folded into
white chocolate cream cheese,
it'll be topped
with candied
pistachio spikes.
You have been Star Baker, right?
I know. Twice.
In a row. Oh, don't.
I forever feel like there's
impending doom on the horizon.
Yeah, me too. Do you? Yeah.
I mean, how did I get
hired for this show?
OK, I mean, I don't
blame you for those feelings.
OK, is that why you tell
me to go away? Yeah.
OK.
Oop...
I am just piping layers of meringue.
I'm doing four discs,
and then if one does break,
I've got three at least.
I'm doing caramel now.
Use a cocktail stick to swirl it.
They're going in for an hour at 130.
Meringue you do for
a very low temperature,
so it's really just
drying it out over time.
So the challenge is to make
sure that it's marshmallowy
and not just...
..chew.
With meringues baking...
Right, next.
..attention turns to
the all-important fillings.
So, every Christmas when I was
younger, there would be
a chocolate orange at
the bottom of our stockings.
Chocolate and orange are the best
flavours together, I reckon.
It's not a Chakraverty Christmas
without a chocolate orange.
Michael's making an orange
creme au beurre filling
and his cake will be decorated
with caramelised hazelnut spikes
and smothered in
a dark chocolate
and orange ganache
with a kick.
Well, there's booze in
the ganache as well. Ah...
A little bit of orange
liqueur in the ganache.
Prue, it's your birthday.
Well, it might be my birthday.
It's very good. Good luck.
And Michael's not the only
baker reaching for the bottle.
This is some amaretto creme pat.
I don't drink, but it's
my husband's favourite drink.
Priya's husband Sean's
tipple of choice
will complement layers
of almond dacquoise
topped with a blueberry
creme au beurre.
Your flavours are generally spot on.
Where you lack
sometimes is the timing.
Yes, I know, I know. Please remember
that on every single bake you do.
I'm gonna buy you a watch.
I know, I know.
I have a watch. It's in the drawer.
One hour remaining.
I feel like really sick.
They're firm. Yay!
They're crispy on the outside
and slightly chewy in the middle.
Oh, they're huge!
Why are they so big?
You and your massive meringues!
Bulbous. Bulbous!
Oven is going off. So, they don't
like temperature change,
so I'm gonna let the oven cool down
with my meringues in there.
Otherwise they crack.
During the daunting
cooling process...
How does this work?
Oh, it's on!
..the bakers must use every minute
to perfect their meringue
cakes' decoration.
This is going to be
the cherry blossom.
It's like really fragile,
because it's made of meringue.
Oh, my God, look at my hands.
I am trying to blow-torch this
to cut out the circles.
I'm tempering chocolate but I'm
pretty certain it hasn't worked.
Sandi, do you know anything about
tempering chocolate? Obviously.
Chocolate with a temper.
It depends what you've said to it.
Dark chocolate, pretty
even-tempered. Yeah.
Milk chocolate... Chocolate.
Furious.
White chocolate, argh!
There you go. Thank you so much.
Everything you need to know
about tempering chocolate.
You should do a baking show.
What the bloody hell is that?
I'm doing ganache.
It's just slightly grainy.
It's not awful but it's slightly
grainy and that's not what I want.
Bakers, you have 30 minutes left.
I don't know why it goes grainy.
I'm going to make that again
as I don't know what on earth
has gone on there.
Just when to take out the meringues.
Oh, I don't like this at all.
There's definitely a less
theatrical way to do that.
Ah, I'm getting stressed.
OK, hazelnut spikes.
Black Forest gateau - it needs
chocolate, it needs cherries.
Look at that. It's voluptuous,
isn't it?
So I've got creme au beurre
blueberry flavoured.
Blue food is weird, isn't it?
I'm stressed. Some people
really dislike bold spices.
The moment of truth.
SANDI: Baked meringue is
incredibly fragile.
I've just got to be
delicate with them.
Stacking it... Oh, God. Oh, God.
..and then weighing it down
with fillings could be disastrous.
I'm a bit scared.
If this works, I may strip.
Actual miracle.
Bakers... You have...
Ten... Minutes.
Even closer? Even closer.
That's not a lot of minutes.
I am running out of time.
Oh, I may or may not get this done.
Oh.
Raspberry and lime curd - last
minute, last minute, last minute.
It's quite a stiff boy, this.
It's a wee bit messy, but aren't
we all a bit messy sometimes?
Oh, yeah, all four layers.
I've remade the ganache.
I can't cover it all on the sides.
Got so much space
between the layers.
This is my chocolate orange ganache.
This is the final layer.
It's quite big.
Bakers, Sandi said
you have one minute. God.
I haven't got a watch.
It could be three hours.
Oh, God, I'm shaking.
That's ready.
I'm done.
Sieve. I just want a sieve.
I don't want to over-gild
the lily, as it were.
Bakers, your time is... up.
I finished something nearly on time.
Yay!
Michael, what are you doing?
Sorry. I was getting the chocolate
off me! It looked weird.
THEY LAUGH
The bakers' meringue cakes will now
face the judgment of Paul and Prue.
Hello, David. Hey, love.
It looks like a painting.
I think it looks absolutely lovely.
For subtitling services, contatct:
waqas.zahoor89@gmail.com
Nice interior.
Now this is when I'm going to get
this layered taste.
For the bottom, one it's clove
then star anise, and then cinnamon.
The dominant thing is spice.
Clove particularly.
It just does not taste
as delicious as it looks.
It's been overwhelmed by the spices.
The meringue is such a beautiful
thing. It's sort of heartbreaking.
It is. It is. David, how, could you?
For something so beautiful. What
have you done? Next time, next time.
Look what you've done to my people!
Next time, I'll just pare it back,
yeah. Thank you, David.
Cool, thank you.
HE SIGHS WITH RELIEF
I really think the colour
of the blueberry cream...
..is horrible. OK.
I know it's partly because we don't
eat a lot of mauve food.
Yeah, it is weird.
But is such a particularly nasty
version of mauve.
Wow.
It just doesn't look appetising.
Yeah.
Is that amaretto? Yeah.
It's a little bit too much.
I think you've slightly
overbaked the meringue. Yeah.
I would've liked to have seen a
little bit more
elaborate piping on the outside.
Yeah.
It looks a bit wonky, doesn't it?
I think it's absolutely delicious.
I think your layers are fantastic.
You know, you've got a little bit of
sharpness coming from the curd,
the raspberries are nice. However...
..the chocolate doesn't go
with it because it's too thick.
It just looks so charming with your
basket handle, or whatever it is.
Very attractive.
You've certainly got the colours. I
mean, it's quite purple, isn't it?
Yeah, it was meant to be
cherry, but...
Your chocolate comes through but
then you're sort of hunting for
another big flavour to come in
and it just doesn't arrive.
It's there if you get a cherry, but
I think you needed a morello cherry
or something with a bit more punch.
OK, thank you. Thank you.
Well, it looks very neat
and I congratulate you
on your little sticks.
Ah, there's too much chocolate.
What'd you say? I think there's
too much chocolate
on the outside. Don't tell him.
The meringue's sweated slightly
inside with it being
en croute, almost...
Yeah. ..with the chocolate.
Cos all the liquid is then soaked
into the meringue
and it's softened it up. OK.
Chocolate, it dominates the whole
thing. OK.
But, I have to say,
I like the flavours.
They're very obvious.
There's orange and chocolate,
and what's better than that?
It's amazing you've managed to get
that much chocolate on your apron.
THEY LAUGH
It does look beautiful.
It's neat, it's very
professional-looking as well.
It's lovely. It's lovely-looking
and quite original.
And it really looks
like a celebration cake.
Oh, that looks gorgeous.
That looks yummy.
The raspberry comes through and you
do get the flavour of the nuts
but you needed to lighten that up,
just take some nuts out. OK.
It would've been much,
much nicer to eat. OK.
It tastes lovely, it looks lovely
and there are too many nuts.
Well done, Steph.
Too many nuts.
Never too many nuts.
I like the way the meringue
has really risen
but it is slightly messy.
It's a little rugged. The one on the
top should've been on the bottom,
the one on the bottom should be
the second from the top. Yeah.
And then these two should be
inverted and put on top of that.
Completely. You end up with, with a
sort of slight rise to the top.
Yeah. Design-wise, it's wanting.
I like the nutty meringue.
I think the texture is great
because it's light.
Oh, lovely. The raspberry jam is
the saviour of this
because everything seems to flow
with it. Yeah, it's good.
You didn't make the jam, did you?
I did. He did.
You did make the jam? I did. I did.
The cheek.
I would, uh,
take him away now if I can.
Come away, come away.
Thank you. Thank you.
Well done, Henry.
That went so well.
Oh, if you had seen me
in the kitchen yesterday.
It was hell and, today,
oh, that was good.
That wasn't good, was it?
But I think everyone had
a bit of a grilling.
They said the chocolate didn't
really go with
raspberries and cream,
and I don't agree.
I mean, chocolate,
raspberries and cream?
After a disappointing Signature
Challenge, the bakers now face
one of the most complex technical
challenges
the Bake Off has ever seen.
Hello, lovely bakers.
Welcome back to your Technical
Challenge which, today,
has been set for you by
the delight that is Prue.
This is all about the detail
and precise measurements.
Oh. So helpful.
As ever, this will be judged blind
so I'm going to have to ask you two
lovelies to skedaddle. Off you pop.
Ah, what are they up to?
I think Prue's going to laminate
some of Paul's recipes. Oh.
They're getting quite dog-eared.
No, fair enough.
Today, Prue would like you to make
six identical,
perfectly layered verrines.
Verrine, of course, the French word.
For?
I don't know that bit. That's all
you've got, OK. It's a French word.
Any thoughts?
I think it roughly translates
as some stuff
pushed into a fiddly glass.
OK, basically, it's a layered
dessert in a glass,
and, today, your verrines should
consist of layers of
a mango compote, a creamy,
coconut panna cotta,
a fresh raspberry jelly,
topped with a coconut and lime
streusel and a short sable biscuit.
You've got two and a half hours.
On your marks... ..Get set. ..Bake!
Despite the verrine's complexity,
Prue's recipe is as basic as ever.
Prue's treated us this week,
hasn't she?
No, I haven't ever heard of it.
What is it? A verrine? No!
This is definitely Prue not Paul,
isn't it?
If it was Paul,
it'd be Angel Delight.
Verrines then, Prue. They're pretty.
They are beautiful.
We have got a mango compote,
coconut panna cotta
and a raspberry jelly,
and then a streusel
with a few mango bits on top.
You've obviously topped it with
a sable biscuit as well. Yeah.
Now, the biscuit
is beautifully baked.
Listen to this snap.
Hmm, that's lovely.
Where are the key elements where
they could go wrong on this?
Not remembering to chill everything
between each layer,
and, if you don't get the
measurements right,
you won't get the layers right.
I've nearly finished mine.
I'm trying to go slowly.
You know when you're a child and you
eat it too fast and you regret it?
Yeah, don't worry. We've got seven
more to try in a bit. Good.
Right, for the sable biscuit make
sable dough, roll thin.
What does it mean, sable?
Salad? What?
It means sand, I believe, in French.
Next, six circles.
Cut out a circle just out of centre
of the middle of the biscuit
and chill. Chill.
If only we could chill.
Did you know what this was? Well,
once they said it was that dessert,
that's in a glass, I think,
well I've definitely had that.
Just layers. Problem is, by dessert,
you're usually quite drunk so...
Could be anything, couldn't it?
Could be anything.
For the mango compote, blitz the
mango to a puree,
pop into a small pan,
add the glucose.
Put equal amounts in the glasses.
I have been practising
my times table.
I've worked out that's 30g and,
if that's wrong,
I'm going to be really embarrassed.
I'm just going to be really
precise.
My students would be so proud.
Chill until set.
Are you all right, Priya?
I think so, yeah.
No, it's just you're not speaking
and that's so rare.
What are you trying to say?
Does she talk the whole time? Yeah.
Not the whole time. Oh, darling. I
don't get out.
I don't get, it's all CBeebies and
Lego in my house. I don't get out.
Is that what it is? Yeah.
So thrilled to be other adults.
Yeah, yeah.
Now on the coconut panna cotta.
I'm following the rules so,
if it's wrong, it's Prue's fault.
I haven't made a panna cotta before.
New territory, again.
I've not done a panna cotta before,
no.
It is just a set-milk dessert.
But this one's coconut.
Right, chilling this
in a water bath.
I'd quite like to chill
This has to be chilled because, if
it goes onto the mango compote warm,
it's going to melt
the mango compote.
Jesus, a lot of ice.
Hello. All right, your jumper
reminds me of Where's Wally.
I really want to find Wally. Where's
Wally? That is not the look
I'm going for, Steph. Damn it,
sorry. I was trying to be cool!
Hello, and welcome to the Bake Off
where I've been teaching Noel
how to make these. How are you
getting on, Noel?
Is that what they're supposed
to look like? Wow, so close.
I think that one's very successful.
OK, bakers, you are halfway through.
Right, so, now I need to bake
my biscuits.
I don't know how long sable
biscuits take to do.
Maybe eight minutes.
Shall I show Paul?
Maybe next batch. Next batch.
Yeah. Gloves are good though,
aren't they?
Like the lion in Wizard of Oz.
AS LION: Put 'em up, put 'em up.
Prue has demanded perfectly baked
sable on top of the verrine.
One more minute.
And perfectly even layers inside it.
WHISPERS: 200 divided by six,
200 divided by six.
40 by three is...
..ten. No, 40 by six.
I'm going to pour 20ml
into each one.
I want really nice, even layers.
So, I need these layers
to be defined and equal.
I hope it's all right.
I don't have a clue.
I should've weighed this
but I didn't have the patience.
Chill until set.
Mustn't drop these sodding things.
TIMER GOES OFF
Another three minutes
on the biscuits.
So I'm making the raspberry jelly.
I'm still waiting for
my panna cotta to cool enough.
Crunch time, isn't it?
Last layer. Don't want to mess it
up. Bakers!
You have half an hour left.
If the panna cotta isn't set...
Oh, my BLEEP! Oh.
..the raspberry jelly will fall
straight through it.
Wish me luck.
You're not going to know
until it sets.
If it sets.
I'm going to start with a teaspoon.
Oh, no! That wasn't good.
It's gone through my panna cotta.
So, they're going back
in the fridge.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes left!
15 minutes!
Unlike me - I've got 15 years.
I mean, I probably could get out
of this but...
..maybe I'll get longer.
Right, for the streusel
make the streusel dough crumble.
Wasn't one of the children in the
Sound of Music
called Streusel or something?
Liesl, Liesl not Streusel!
Sugar, makes it sweet.
Right, take the streusel onto
two, lined, baking sheets and bake.
Two minutes maximum.
That will not take long.
Whoa!
It says spread a layer of streusel.
I'm on it, I'm on it.
I'm trying to make it as even
as I can right out to the edges.
Right, diced mango.
OK, I'm doing it little by little.
The layers seem fairly distinct.
There's a couple of messy ones
but I'm just going to put them at
the back.
Like they won't notice that!
Decorate the biscuits
and sit on top of the glass.
Oh, bloody hell, they only just fit.
Look at that.
These don't fit in the glasses.
Don't tell me
this now doesn't fit on top of here.
Bakers, you have one minute.
What?
Oh, they can, they can,
they really want to.
Are you joking?
SHE SIGHS
Oh, it's all very stressful,
isn't it?
Come on, darling.
Oh, I feel alive.
PLEADING: Stay.
No-one move in this vicinity.
Shaky hands.
Just need that.
There we go.
OK. I'm, I'm stuck. Oh.
Time is up.
Please bring your verrines
up to the table.
Oh, this is...
I can't actually do this.
PRIYA: No-one breathe.
I can barely breathe.
MICHAEL: I'm behind you,
Priya, I'm behind you.
ROSIE: Mine's shaking, Henry.
You can do it.
ALICE: They are very precariously
balanced.
MICHAEL: Careful, careful of Henry.
HENRY: Priya, make way.
Henry, you realise you've worn a red
tie with a red shirt.
Not now. Not now, now is
not the moment, darling.
This is ridiculous.
BIRDS TWEET
Prue and Paul are expecting verrines
layered with mango compote,
coconut panna cotta, raspberry jelly
and topped with a sable biscuit.
If they taste as good as they look,
we'll be very pleased.
Well, you've got the chocolate.
Biscuit breaks very easily.
That's very nice sable.
The textures are all good.
Hm, tastes lovely.
Right, moving on.
The layers are a bit flatter,
aren't they?
I think their biscuits
are very slightly overbaked.
But they taste OK.
I must say, this is so delicious
I'm really enjoying it.
OK, a bit uneven on the biscuit
again but very delicate.
They are lovely and thin.
The top jelly's not quite set,
is it?
And it's a little bit wavy.
Yeah, it is.
Now these look quite nice.
The panna cotta's a bit thicker
but it could be even thicker,
couldn't it? Hm,
that mango is still not quite set.
Yeah, OK.
I think it's probably
a bit too much streusel.
Where's the mango?
Ah, didn't go in there.
That jelly is runny. It's not set.
Right. The biscuit does
sit in there nicely.
It tastes good
but it is slightly thick.
And, down the bottom, same
problem of not straight lines.
OK, texture's good.
See the lines are quite good.
The lines are excellent.
Flavour's excellent.
Streusel's very good.
The actual jelly's set quite
nicely, actually.
That's quite smooth.
Interesting.
Prue and Paul will now rank
the bakers from worst to best.
In seventh place we have this one.
Who's that?
Priya, it tasted delicious
but yours was not quite set
and there was too much streusel.
In sixth spot is this one.
Look at those
lines down at the bottom.
It's about being even.
Rosie came fifth,
Henry fourth
and Steph came third.
And, in second spot is...
This came down to how neat the lines
were because pretty much
everything in there was spot on.
Which leaves us with this one.
Alice.
APPLAUSE
Alice, this was
as near perfect as we got.
It was so good! Yeah, I was so happy
but I was also so surprised.
Fourth time second in the technical.
Never going to be first.
I know I'm in the bottom
and obviously I'll be upset to go.
I feel like perhaps dessert week
just isn't for me.
Aw!
It does mean that there's more
pressure on tomorrow.
We'll have to wait and see.
Well done!
There is just one challenge
remaining in dessert week.
So interesting day yesterday
because the signature,
by and large, disappointing, and the
technical, by and large, thrilling.
Was brilliant. NOEL: At this stage,
I always feel like Steph,
she's around about Star Baker level.
PAUL: Yeah, and I would say
the same about Alice as well.
NOEL: Has anyone ever got it
three times in a row?
PAUL: I think it'd be second.
Coming into the showstopper,
I think, really,
Michael and Priya
have to save themselves today.
Come on, Priya,
stop talking cos you're always late.
NOEL: Her baking career...
It's going to get worse.
..is like my school report. "Turns
up late and never stops talking."
THEY CHUCKLE
NOEL: Morning, Bakers.
Welcome back to the tent.
It's time for
your showstopper challenge.
Today, Paul and Prue would love you
to make a celebratory bombe dessert.
It must be moulded
into a semi-spherical
or fully spherical shape.
And it should contain
at least one baked element
plus two other dessert elements,
such as ice cream or bavarois
to make the perfect bombe.
Your celebratory bombe must be
as spectacular on the outside
as it is on the inside. I feel like
we're saying bombe quite a lot.
I can't get enough of it.
Bombe-da-de-bombe. Bombe-bombe.
You've got four and a half hours.
On your marks... ..Get set. ..Bake!
I've had lots of disasters
this week trying to make this.
I'm just scared that, like,
one element will go wrong
and then the whole thing'll
just, like, literally fall apart.
PRUE: A celebratory bombe
really means a round dessert.
It's a little bit of luxury,
a bombe.
Probably going to build
into a mould.
The critical time is when they let
it all out cos you're going to
have so many different layers,
so many different textures.
They've all got to be
set at the same time.
If one layer collapses,
the probability of all of them
collapsing is very, very high.
I hope that out will come
a perfect slice
of every single element.
This is tricky.
NOEL: For Michael,
a show stopping bombe
isn't the only cause for
celebration. It's my birthday.
I might just go into the judging
blind drunk, see what happens.
Hi, Michael. Hi, there.
Hi, sweetie.
Happy birthday, Michael. Thank you.
Didn't expect to have
my birthday in here.
How old are you? I'm 26.
Fantastic age. Tell us all about
your bombe. What are you doing?
Uh, I am making
a Black Forest bombe.
So, in the middle,
we have the cherry jelly,
and on top of that is a chocolate
and almond mousse,
then coating on the outside will be
chocolate and cherry
Italian meringue.
Chocolate and cherry. So you had
too much chocolate yesterday. Yeah.
It sounds like
a lot of chocolate still.
It sounds like a lot of chocolate,
yeah.
To balance
the four chocolate elements
in his ornately decorated bombe,
Michael is creating
a creamy base layer
of rich, cherry cheesecake.
What have you used
to get the cherry flavour?
Um, I've used freeze-dried cherries.
I struggled with, uh, getting it to
set cos, when I was putting
cherries in, I was getting quite
a lot of the juice. Yes.
So I thought freeze-dried
might help.
Oh, no...
He's giving nothing away, though.
Well, I think
you're doing everything right.
Thank you. Good luck, Michael.
Thanks very much.
He must be really good at poker.
He eats it and he's like, nothing.
Michael's Black Forest gateau...
Right, rum...
..isn't the only classic dessert
that's about to be bombed.
I think tiramisu means,
uh, "pick me up" in Italian
because of the coffee.
And I drink a lot of coffee.
Literally, between lessons
just downing cups of coffee.
In Alice's
teacher-friendly tiramisu,
there's espresso coffee
in the genoise sponge,
and chocolate mousse.
This will be layered with
pistachio parfait
and praline,
and a mascarpone cream with
a large measure of spiced rum.
Hello. Hello.
You don't look so flustered today.
Maybe it's the... the rum
as well that I've put in the...
You've been drinking. I've just had
a couple of, you know...
I had to taste it and check that it
was OK. There's a lot of pressure
in this competition. I'm surprised
some people don't just
do it smashed. Well... Because
there's alcohol around. Shall we?
What would you drink on a night out?
Anything. Anything.
To ensure they'll be celebrating
when they unveil their bombes...
Oh, right.
..the bakers can use a sponge lining
to hold its set layers in place.
Going to give it two more minutes.
Two more minutes.
That means we've got two minutes
to talk about your birthday.
Whoo!
I do have one of these.
I've got you
a Paul and Prue strippergram.
Amazing.
Priya is also hoping
her sponge will help her
hold her place in the competition.
It's a fatless sponge
so it's quite light and spongy
but it soaks up
the flavour quite well.
This is creme de cassis,
blackcurrant liqueur.
I was using Chambord initially,
which is raspberry,
and it just smells like Calpol.
Priya's future in the competition
rests on completing
her liqueur-soaked
sponge lining
to hold layers of
dark chocolate mousse,
a summer fruits bavarois
and dark chocolate ganache.
She hopes to surround it all
with dozens of hand-piped
raspberry meringue shards.
You worried about time?
No, I'll be OK with this. That's why
I choose mousses cos the mousses set
a lot quicker than some of the other
things. Now you've said this before.
I know, I know but I've practised.
I've made so many bombes.
You've said that before.
So many bombes have gone in the bin.
This cannot happen today. I know,
it can't, it can't, it can't.
Right, sponges.
Whilst most of the bakers are
attempting a safety approach
to bombe construction...
I'm now lining it.
This is so satisfying.
OK, you need to get out more,
darling, that's really...
Just leave me alone with my cake.
OK.
..Steph's chance for
an historic third Star Baker award
could be far from secure.
So, I'm starting
with the chocolate -
what's it called - mousse.
She's chosen not to line her bombe
with sponge.
This is round the outside.
It's the main structure.
So, I'll be chilling it
for as long as possible.
If her dark chocolate mousse
holds, it will surround
a centre of rich coffee bavarois
on top of an amaretto-soaked
joconde base
and, to decorate,
Steph's taking an even bigger risk.
So, I'm going for
a chocolate glaze over the top.
Will the chocolate be shiny?
Um, probably not
hold its shine too well.
Only because I'm going to need to
put it in the fridge
so it's likely to lose a little
bit of that shine. OK. OK.
You've stumped them.
It sounds fine.
I don't think that's stumped.
That's probably, like, "Hmm..."
Oh, hang on, I've just gotta
do a time call.
Put your sword down.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
Halfway through.
That's cheating. I know,
still feels like a win, though.
Time is now the bakers'
greatest enemy.
OK, need that to be a bit cooler.
Every minute their bombes are out
of the chiller
increases the chance of collapse.
Just going to leave my pistachio
chilling
before I put the mousse on top.
This is just the coffee bavarois
and I'm just popping it in
multiple bowls in the hope
that one of them sets.
The bombe can melt or not hold its
form or be generally problematic.
But in a bid to speed up
the setting process...
Got a hot date in the freezer.
..Henry is deploying
a secret weapon.
What are the little circles for?
I'm going to mousse in, circle,
mousse in, circle, mousse in.
So I can freeze all the layers at
once but separately. OK.
And then de-mould it
and then that fits nicely.
That's very clever. Well done.
Thank you.
You taught Prue something. Yeah.
Henry plans to replace his cardboard
with cinnamon meringue
to separate his layers
of Bramley apple mousse
and spiced honey mousse
which will be encased in a cinnamon
sponge filled with
cinnamon Chantilly cream.
Here we go.
So, I'm just making my layers.
What the hell's Henry doing?
And the boards are to
separate my layers of mousse
just so they don't seep
into one another.
Can somebody open the freezer
for me? Yeah.
Henry's finally gone mad.
Don't breathe.
While Henry attempts to set
all his layers at once...
Nailed it.
..David is taking
an even bigger gamble.
No-one else is doing
a sorbet or an ice cream.
It is quite tough because I'm doing
a sorbet that needs to be frozen
and then a jelly and a mousse
that just need to be chilled.
So, it is a little bit risky.
I like risks.
David's sharp lemon and shiso leaf
sorbet will join a creamy,
white chocolate and raspberry mousse
and a raspberry and rose jelly.
My partner's from Bulgaria
and my brother and sister-in-law
live in Bulgaria and that's where
roses come from.
90% of the roses for all perfume
come from Bulgaria.
So, I've eaten a lot of
rose desserts.
Romance is also
in the air for Rosie.
It was my parents' ruby wedding
anniversary last month
so it's going to be red
on the outside and my colours
going through it are a sunset.
Rosie's romantic sunset tribute
to Mum and Dad
will feature honey cake,
mango bavarois,
lemon and hibiscus
mousse,
and caramelised,
salted white chocolate.
40 years married? Yes.
I think you deserve at
the very least a celebratory bombe.
Yeah, I really hope it's not like,
"Happy wedding anniversary!
"Here's a puddle!"
Cos that's bit sad, then.
90 minutes remaining.
Welcome to the least laddy
lad's club.
We're discussing the setting
temperature of gelatine.
A very masculine conversation
actually. Wow. I wish I cared.
With every additional layer...
Very stressed.
..the bakers' bombes
get harder to set.
That's cherry jelly
with kirsch in it.
This is a really technical technique
called tossing it in.
Ah, there is no way of doing these
things without plopping.
So now we have to prepare
the coffee bavarois.
Tastes all right. I think.
I'm sure they'll have
a separate opinion.
As well as perfectly set
layers on the inside...
Sorbet out.
Prue and Paul have demanded bombes
that are beautifully decorated
on the outside.
I'm going to start
making my meringues.
Time's going loads quicker
than I hoped.
Time's not really your friend,
is it? Time's not my friend.
It's not my friend. I spoke to time.
Time hates you.
I've gone for the nut brittle first,
mirror glaze in a minute.
I'm struggling big time.
How long have we got?
Bakers, you have one hour left.
One hour remaining.
No-one's listening to me.
I've got this, leave this with me.
Bakers, you have one hour,
one hour left.
Bakers, one hour.
SIREN BLARES
OK.
SIREN CONTINUES
HE SIGHS
The bakers now face an agonising,
drawn out decision.
I'm not worried.
Their bombes need to chill for
long enough to completely set.
I just want to leave it in there
for long as I possibly can
at this point. But they also need
to turn them out with enough time
remaining for decoration.
How long would you give yourself
to do this at home?
Couple of days. Couple of...!
A week.
NOEL LAUGHS
I might just have a cup of coffee.
Get some marking done.
I don't get how people have got
nothing to do.
Noughts and crosses.
Yes!
What's the matter? I'm stressed.
OK, cooking's all about love, right?
Yeah.
Cooking's all about creating
this wonderful thing
for the people that you love.
So that's...
Does that mean I love Paul?
Well, everybody also has challenges
in the kitchen. OK. Yeah.
This could be a yoga move.
31 minutes.
Everything is ready to go.
I mean, I can pipe the meringue on
it in ten minutes if I have to.
I'd rather not.
30 minutes to go.
Right, I need to do some building.
No idea if it's enough time.
Yes.
It's the moment of truth for Henry's
all-in-one-setting gamble.
Against all odds, we may have had
a miracle happen here.
Oh! So many miracles have
occurred right now.
And he's not the only one
hoping for a miracle.
Ooh, my heart's going.
Proof is in whether it
actually turns out.
Panic.
Ugh.
If this comes away, I'm converting
to some other religion.
There's cardboard in there
somewhere, though.
That's the problem.
Can everyone avert their eyes?
Oh, God.
Ugh.
Where's the sodding cardboard?
Wow.
No.
It's very frozen.
It's there. There it is.
Ta-da!
Done. Finished.
It's all finished.
Oh, God.
I need to get this
bit off its cakeboard and dollop it.
That's the honey mousse.
They look good, actually.
Come on.
Ah.
Oh, no. Oh.
Some of the cake is
stuck to the inside of it.
There's the apple.
Oh, my God, the apple's worked.
Mousse.
Mousse on top of a sorbet.
This is madness!
I just need that cake to fall out.
SHE SIGHS
Ah, thank God!
Ah, God.
I thought it wasn't going to happen.
If she wins again Star Baker,
that'll be three in a row.
Go, Steph. Do you want that
to happen? Yeah.
Secretly though you don't, do you?
Get some records broken. Yes!
I definitely want Steph to win.
Definitely.
What about you?
I would like Steph to get a third
Star Baker. Go, Steph.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes,
just 15 minutes.
God, this is not fun, is it?
This could be the worst moment.
It's gonna go, it's going to go.
Oh, for god's sake.
Right, what temperature are we on?
This is the mirror glaze
that I'm making.
I don't know whether to take it off,
pull it out. I can't break the cake.
Blowtorch meringue. Helps it to set.
Nervousness. No, that's no good.
Oh, God.
OK, we might be all right.
Right, come on, come on.
Nearly at 30 so should cover
my bombe completely.
Come on. Wow.
Ooh! OK!
Oh, played tricks on me
for a moment there, didn't it?
The sorbet inside, it's pretty
sold now. I love that smell.
HENRY COUGHS
There's a massacre of chocolate
right now.
Five minutes left.
Ta-da-da!
You're not going very fast. If I
break these, then I'm in trouble.
Then it's over. And if I break them,
then I can't make any more.
I can help with one minute to go,
what do you want? Oh, OK, right.
So I need you to turn the turntable
as I pipe. Go.
Good luck, Henry.
I'm not going to look.
It'll probably go un-mirrored.
Things can happen between
there and here.
Go. How long do we have?
Whatever you're doing, you need to
finish it in 60 seconds!
I'm burning the cake board.
Ooh!
Bakers, your time is up!
Please place your bombes at the end
of your work stations.
Sounds weird.
My rose, it does look
a bit like a cabbage, doesn't it?
Off you pop. Pour yourself a G&T,
it's your birthday.
And relax. Have two.
Happy birthday, Michael.
Happy birthday.
It's over.
HE BLOWS HORN
We did it.
It's judgment time for
the celebratory bombe desserts.
Steph, please will you bring up
your showstopper?
Do you need a hand? Probably.
Well, your mirror glaze has
certainly worked.
You've got the beautiful shine
of the mirror with
the lines of the white chocolate
with the brittle. That is stunning.
Let's hope it tastes as good
as it looks.
So it's a chocolate mousse,
uh, coffee bavarois.
The mirror glaze is so lovely
and thin.
The chocolate mousse is just what
a chocolate mousse should be.
It melts in your mouth.
Bavarois' lovely.
I could just eat that all.
SANDI CHUCKLES
That's one of the best things
I've had to eat for a long time.
SANDI: Yeah!
The mousse is perfect
and the coffee with the mousse
as well, which is so light,
it's like you've been doing this
for years, just making bombes.
Well done, Steph. Thank you.
Well done. Yay!
Well, it certainly looks
celebratory, doesn't it?
I don't think I'd have blow-torched
it because the colour's so vibrant.
OK. Spoils it a little bit.
Oh, my goodness.
There is a base of honey cake,
mango bavarois and
lemon and hibiscus mousse.
Well, that is certainly colourful.
Mousse is very fool-like
rather than mousse.
It's not really smooth.
They're all very interesting
flavours,
but I don't think the mango goes
with the others so well. OK.
It's a bit clumsy and
the colours are...
It reminds me of Noel.
THEY LAUGH
Well, it's really pretty.
Most elegantly done and unusual.
It's beautiful.
The base is a lemon
and pistachio genoise.
Then it's a raspberry
and rose jelly,
then it's a lemon and shiso sorbet,
topped with a raspberry
and white chocolate mousse.
Perfect layers.
I've never had shiso in this form
and I can't really taste it,
but the lemony flavour is fantastic.
Try it with that.
THEY LAUGH
Sorbet's delicious
cos it is so sharp,
it hits you right at the back
of the tongue.
Jelly's a little bit too rubbery.
If I drop it on the floor,
it'd probably bounce back up
and hit me in the face.
Michael, please bring up
your showstopper.
Wow!
It looks like something
straight from a 1970s sweet trolley.
It looks like the Queen Mum's
hat or something.
But let's see what
this is like inside.
So it's got a chocolate mousse,
a cherry jelly
and a cherry cheesecake.
Wow.
Michael, the cheesecake
is, um, running.
I don't know whether it's just
not had time to set
or you didn't have
the mixture right. OK.
It does taste like
a black forest gateau.
The almond kicks in.
Really like the jelly which has
got terrific punch.
I think you've done a great job
with the flavours.
I think the overall look
is a bit...
..bit gaudy. OK.
Could've been worse. Well done.
I can go home happy now.
Beautiful. Very beautiful.
It looks as you would
expect it to look.
It's tiramisu colours.
The sort of deliberate unevenness
of the steps are just perfect.
I just hope that coffee's there
and all the beautiful textures...
And the rum. ..are in there as well.
And a lot of rum, yeah!
It is a layer of mocha mousse,
coffee-soaked genoise sponge,
a pistachio praline parfait.
The layers are beautiful
and delicate
and it's held together nicely.
Mmm, it's beautiful.
It's delicate, the coffee is
beautiful with the sponge.
It's lovely.
The pistachio comes through
as a little bit of texture as well.
I think the whole thing's a triumph.
You've made a tiramisu bombe,
well done. Thank you.
Thank you, Alice. Well done.
PRIYA: You can breathe, Alice.
You can breathe.
Priya, would you like to bring up
your showstopper?
I think it does look quite elegant,
the colours are nicely laid out.
So I've got summer berry bavarois
and a chocolate mousse,
raspberry sponge.
The sponge is actually baked
beautifully
and it's still light, which is nice.
Nice chocolate mousse.
My only quarrel with the
whole thing was that I think
the chocolate mousse is very sweet.
The raspberry is not.
It doesn't sort of hold up
against the chocolate. OK.
I think if you can instruct diners
to eat first the bavarois
and then the mousse, they'd be happy
but not the other way around. OK.
Thank you very much, Priya.
Henry, would you like to bring up
your showstopper, please?
It's very simple, very elegant.
It looks like an igloo. Igloo. OK.
That's been scorched.
Inside it's a cinnamon sponge
and there are two layers of a
slightly-spiced honey mousse
and one layer of
Bramley apple mousse.
I think the cake's a bit tough.
Hunting down the apple.
If you don't get the apple,
all you get is cinnamon. Right.
You needed something else in there
as well because it's a bit bland.
And the cake is very stodgy.
Sort of disappointing.
You OK?
You seem to be in your
element today.
Well, yes, I love this.
This is my idea of heaven.
They started so badly with the
meringues that I was a despairing.
But anyway,
they've pulled themselves up.
But I tell you what I've found most
disappointing - this is
a baking competition, and both Rosie
and Henry made dreadful cakes.
Coming into this, Priya and Michael
were in a little bit of trouble, and
I think Rosie and certainly Henry
have fallen into that situation
where you end up with four people -
Priya, Michael, Henry and Rosie
are all in trouble.
The two moments when Prue most went
"yum" was the tiramisu by Alice,
and Steph's. Well, Steph set the bar
pretty high, I thought
you were going to give her
a handshake. It was perfection.
And I would say
the same about Alice as well.
But Alice came first
in the technical.
I think both those two guys
are in line for Star Baker.
What about David?
Could he not get Star Baker?
I mean, he came second in technical
and this is absolutely lovely.
The only trouble is the jelly.
The jelly was tough.
The jelly was terrible.
Even I can make jelly.
How do you make bad jelly?
By putting too much gelatine in.
You probably use a packet
and it's all measured out for you.
How dare you!
And suspended fruit in it as well,
at your birthday.
This is unbelievable!
Well done, Bakers, that's the end
of dessert week, I don't think
I've ever heard Prue say yum quite
so many times, so well done.
It's my privilege and pleasure to
announce the Star Baker.
The Star Baker this week is...
..Steph.
Doing it for the fringes.
Ah, Bakers, unfortunately,
that means I've got the horrible job
of announcing the person
who's going home.
And this gets tougher and tougher.
The person who's leaving us
this week is...
..Priya.
Aw!
I've learned so much, Paul.
Sorry. I have! I learned so much.
It's felt like such a privilege
to be in the tent and...
I want to make sure...
Of course I'm going to cry,
of course I'll cry!
But I left work a year ago
and I was a bit stuck.
And I thought, I'm just going to do
the things that I enjoy.
And do you know what it's meant?
It's meant to me that...
..if you just start with
the things that you really enjoy,
you can't go wrong.
God, I need to give her a massive,
massive hug now.
I've spent the past hour before
that prepping my little goodbyes.
I was fully prepped.
I knew what I was
going to nick from the tent.
I knew I was going to nick
the apron,
was going to get a spoon,
maybe a bowl, a whisk.
I think I was deathly flirting with
the bottom there, wasn't I?
Giving the bottom a cheeky wink!
PRUE: Well done, little Steph!
Thank you.
You can't go on doing this,
you know. I know!
I was convinced that Alice would
have had that, then.
I'm just like... Oh, what!
Hopefully now, three times in a row,
maybe it will sink in,
how great she is.
Hello? Hi, Mum.
I just got Star Baker again.
Oh, my God, Steph. I know.
Bloody hell! Stop swearing!
Next time...
Are we rocking it?
..Bake Off hits
the festival circuit...
Bonfire, carnival...
..with seasonal treats...
Christmas. Hot cross bun.
..party pastries...
Something is burning.
..and the most magical
carnival cakes...
..ever to be seen in the tent.
Looks like a stack of egg
sandwiches at an afternoon tea.
That's what I was going for. Yeah.
That's what you were going for?
Egg and cress.
Subtitles by Red Bee Media